you ever get those little
aging liver spots on your skin
if you do i'm going to show you how to
get rid of them i'm going to show you
what's behind them okay now you can call
them aging spots dark spots or liver
spots but in actuality it's not
necessarily the liver that's causing
those spots
it's really just too much of this thing
right here called melanin okay melanin
is a pigment on your skin
it's what gives your skin a certain
color
and this pigment protects against
uv radiation the sun gives off a lot of
different waves or you could say
radiation it's like uv
waves you have the visible light
spectrum which involves all these
different colors and then you have
infrared and so if you got the sun
you're constantly getting hit by
certain amounts of radiation
and
melanin is there to protect you against
this uv uh
very specific band of
energy and so this pigment melanin
is very similar to the pigment in plants
okay like chlorophyll is a pigment in
plants there's other pigments too that
also protect the plant from uv radiation
and these pigments are really
antioxidants so melanin is an
antioxidant and so the question is what
causes
too much melanin okay like during the
summer months you might notice that you
have more of these spots than in the
winter
because of this uv radiation
as you get older you might have more
spots if you're a diabetic you might
notice more of these spots
if you're pregnant you might have more
of this pigmentation if you are birth
control pills or are taking hormone
replacement therapy because of estrogen
you might notice more of this
pigmentation also when you're under a
lot of stress you can notice more of
this pigmentation why because excessive
estrogen increases melanin excessive
cortisol increases melanin excessive
insulin increases
melanin and so you have all these
triggers that are increasing melanin
okay the purpose is to protect you
against uv
and also act as an antioxidant so in
your mind you might think melanin is a
bad thing no it's a it's trying to help
you so the real reason why melanin is
increasing it's trying to counter
all the free radical damage and
oxidation that's happening in your skin
you have a tremendous amount of
networks of antioxidants in your skin
way more than in your blood okay even
like vitamin c you have certain amounts
of vitamin c in your blood but you have
way more in your skin and so when your
antioxidants
go down in your skin
guess what's gonna have to take up the
slack and do the work of these
antioxidants
melanin okay so when you see these
little spots on your skin realize
they're trying to help you and they're
an indication that you are low in
antioxidants in your skin you're low in
vitamin c and other antioxidants and so
when you look at the mechanism behind
melanin there's this enzyme here called
tyrosinase that actually it's kind of a
brownie enzyme and it's going to be
necessary to make melanin
and so if you look up tyrosinase
inhibitors okay things that will inhibit
this and help balance it out
they're all antioxidants okay you have
cinnamon
cocoa bean
grape seed extract green tea
aloe
vitamin c
licorice
quercetin
and melatonin melatonin okay different
than melanin
this is like the sleep hormone but it
does a lot of other things this is a
the most powerful antioxidant in your
entire
body okay and take a little guess what
the best trigger for increasing more
melatonin is
it's actually sun
but not the full spectrum the infrared
part of the sun which by the way is like
50 of the sun so is it the sun that's
really causing this these dark spots no
not necessarily now now if you're going
on sun and you're baking your skin and
you're cooking your skin and you're
burning yes okay that's that's excessive
amount but typically it's because you're
going out in the sun
and you don't have enough antioxidants
because your diet isn't right and this
melanin has to overcompensate and make
up the damage but the cool thing about
getting
infrared from the sun
and generating melatonin is that you
don't necessarily have to expose your
skin
to the sun directly because the infrared
wave goes right to your clothing it goes
right to your hat goes right into your
skull and it can start to build up
melatonin in your body okay so there's
really two things that you can do one is
if you want to see some quick changes
you can pretty much do any one of these
okay in some type of cream and put it
directly in your skin
like the vitamin c serum works really
really good on that okay but the problem
is you have to keep using it until you
build up your antioxidants in your skin
people don't realize that this is really
an internal problem they focus just on
the topical
problem and they keep rubbing it in
there and wondering why it keeps coming
back well because the real problem is
internally so you can use any one of
these as a coping mechanism but then
eventually you want to increase the
antioxidant levels internally in your
body so you have them in their skin so
how do you do that well
this relates to eating more raw food i'm
talking about
large salads vegetables things like that
not just cooked vegetables right eating
foods high in zinc zinc is so important
for your skin and also building up your
networks of antioxidants okay
fasting by the way
is a huge trigger
of
building up your body's antioxidants
okay fasting and also exercise both of
them
very powerful and this is why fasting is
so good for your skin
also of course avoiding sugar and stress
because both of these
deplete you of antioxidants okay
and then of course if you're on the sun
avoid
burning your skin be on the sun on a
regular basis but then cover your skin
before you burn okay
now if you have not seen my video the
melatonin it's it's a really good one
that will explain how to increase that
from the sun
check it out i put it right here
you